welcome back to cbs mornings it's been
exactly one year since the taliban took
over afghanistan after 20 years of
fighting with the u.s and its allies we
all remember those very chaotic scenes
at the kabul airport as american forces
withdrew from the country since then the
taliban has cemented its control
over the weekend taliban fighters broke
up a protest by dozens of afghan women
by firing their weapons into the air mts
tab is in kabul for more on this story
with us mts good morning to you the
picture is very scary
indeed gail and good morning to you well
the taliban is really celebrating the
one year anniversary of its takeover of
afghanistan and indeed the end of two
decades of fighting but for the afghans
we've been speaking to today is a day of
sadness anger
and fear
the tumultuous end to america's longest
war immortalized in these chaotic scenes
the taliban's lightning fast takeover of
afghanistan just weeks before the united
states planned military withdrawal
triggered such intense panic that
thousands of afghans stormed the kabul
airport in a desperate attempt to flee
the country some even clinging to a
moving u.s military aircraft as it rose
into the sky
and falling to their deaths
it's an anguish sakir razai and his
family live with to this day
his 17 year old son zubi was found among
the dead while his 19 year old son zaki
who had also clung to the aircraft
hasn't been seen or heard from since
take us back to one year ago
the only memories i have are that my
children's bodies were mangled and torn
to pieces he says it's one year that
i've been searching for my son
this is the calamity that i remember
but for the taliban today is a day of
joy as hundreds fill the central kabul
square just yards from where the u.s
embassy once stood waving flags and
chanting god is great rejoicing that
it's back in control of a country it
once ruled from 1996 up until the 2001
allied invasion that followed the 9 11
attacks as the taliban celebrates its
one year anniversary of taking over
afghanistan make no mistake this is a
nation that remains internationally
isolated with not a single country
recognizing the taliban government
and yet the taliban's day-to-day focus
seems to be more about controlling the
lives of women they've told them not to
go to work have said girls over the age
of 12 cannot go to most formal schools
how to place restrictions on women's
freedom of movement akof mahajan speaks
for the ministry of vice and virtue
which has issued these decrees
islamic law permits women to travel
alone for up to 48 miles without a male
guardian he says but not any further
because a woman is a creation of god
that cannot endure difficult journeys
can you at least see
why people look at your government look
at your ministry with suspicion
particularly on the specific issue of
women
no he says
we don't listen to the world as far as
our islamic law prescribes we will not
yield to the world's unwarranted
pressures
despite the risk some afghan women
continue to defy the taliban in a rare
protest this weekend around 40 women
took to the streets of kabul to demand
their rights chanting bread work and
freedom
but were instead met with bullets as
thaliban security forces fired live
rounds into the air to disperse
one year into the taliban's takeover of
afghanistan and the nation also remains
in the grips of what the u.n considers
the world's worst humanitarian crisis
after the biden administration froze
billions in assets from the central bank
and foreign donors pulled vast amounts
of funding that once made up three
quarters of the nation's annual budget
now as the taliban celebrates its
one-year anniversary and indeed the end
of america's longest war it has to be
said that this country is far less
violent than it was while it was in
conflict but when you consider the fact
that the taliban continues to strip away
the most basic rights and the economy
here remains in free fall for many
afghans the future remains
extremely bleak tony
starvation loss of rights is about as
bad as a lot of people feared it would
be mts tie up for us in afghanistan mts
thank you very much